One of the things that we know about all types
of crime is that they are highly concentrated
in a small number of places.
But why is crime concentrated in so few places?
The simplest answer to that question is that
opportunities for different types of crime
concentrate in some places more than others.
Shoplifting tends to concentrate on streets
with lots of shops, especially those shops
that sell items that are easy to steal.
Meanwhile, alcohol-related violence at weekends
tends to concentrate in areas with lots of
places selling alcohol, especially bars that
don’t mind selling drinks to people who
are already drunk.
Sometimes a particular type of place will
create opportunities for multiple different
types of crime.
For example, this street has lots of cars
parked in it and also has lots of houses,
so there might be opportunities for both residential
burglaries and vehicle thefts.
But not all crimes happen in the same places.
Fuel theft tends to concentrate along major
roads where petrol stations are sited, while
theft of farm equipment is much more likely
to happen in the countryside.
Saying that crime is concentrated because
opportunities for crime are concentrated might
seem a bit obvious.
But understanding how opportunities for crime
concentrate turns out to be really important
in understanding and preventing crime more
generally.
One way that we can better understand opportunities
for crime is to use a model like the routine
activities approach.
This model doesn’t tell us where a specific
crime will happen, but instead tells us where
opportunities for crime are most likely to
occur.
The routine activities approach says that
an opportunity for crime happens when a potential
offender and a potential crime target come
together at a place, as long as there is no-one
there who can stop that crime occurring.
A potential offender is anyone who has the
knowledge and skills necessary to commit a
particular crime, and who feels that committing
a crime is a valid thing to do in a given
set of circumstances.
A target for crime is whatever the offender
is trying to do something to.
For a violent crime, the target is the victim
– the person being assaulted, for example.
For property crimes, the target is whatever
the offender is trying to steal or damage.
And for crimes like drug dealing, the target
is the person the dealer is trying to sell
the drugs to.
Sometimes offenders and targets will come
together without creating a crime opportunity,
because there is someone present who can stop
any crime occurring.
These people are known as controllers of crime,
although you might sometimes hear them referred
to as guardians.
Controllers are people who can make offenders
less likely to attack targets, make targets
themselves less vulnerable, or make places
less suitable for offenders and targets to
come together.
In most cases controllers aren’t people
who are paid to prevent crime like police
officers – usually controllers are people
who prevent crime incidentally while going
about their day-to-day activities.
For example, a potential burglar’s partner
might insist they go to the cinema on a particular
evening, incidentally stopping the person
finding any suitable burglary targets.
Likewise, if someone travels on a late-night
train looking for a sleeping passenger they
can sexually assault, the presence of other
passengers might make them decide the risk
of offending is too high.
Sometimes the routine activities approach
is represented using the crime triangle.
The basic idea here is that all three sides
of the triangle – offenders [PAUSE] targets
[PAUSE] and places – influence how many
opportunities for crime there will be, with
controllers able to influence each side of
the triangle.
Since offenders and targets are both concentrated
in particular places, we can use this to explain
why different crimes concentrate in some places
more than others.
But it’s important to remember that different
combinations of offenders, targets and controllers
create different opportunities for different
crimes, which explains why we see different
types of crime cluster in different places.
This is important because it means that we
will usually need to analyse different types
of crime separately, for example by creating
separate maps for different crime types rather
than showing multiple types of crime on a
single map.
To summarise:
Opportunities for crime are concentrated in
some places more than others
Different crimes concentrate in different
places because different features of the environment
create opportunities for different crimes
We can use the routine activities approach
to help understand why crime concentrates
in particular places